what makes a great story oh my god what
makes a great story well it's a good
question I have a friend who's like a
real writer writer and he always gets on
me because I don't I don't care a lot
about plot and I think there's probably
two camps maybe there's people who care
about character and there are people who
care about plot and I don't know if
that's that's part of it I think like I
think it just has to be there has to be
a reality to it I think that that for me
rather than like you know it's funny
because I was just talking to my
students about this there has been this
thing in recent years and it's not new
but I could say in the last 5 to 7 years
where the value of a story is related
directly to whether or not the audience
can cannot anticipate what the ending is
gonna be in other words the twist has
become so suddenly the gold standard of
what a great story in other words I
didn't see it coming that's what makes
it a great story you got me you know
that's what makes it a great story and I
feel like that's kind of cheap you know
in a way so I feel like it has to be
character based that the characters have
to be real first and I'll almost forgive
a plot that is not so clever if the
characters are strong and real that's
that's to me that's my standard at least
now that's right so if the characters
seem too much like they're acting
quote-unquote you know even though it
must it's a great story and you didn't
see the ending coming to you that
doesn't I think I think characters that
serve the plot are less interesting the
characters and characters that motivate
plot like there's there's a certain
philosophy I'm sure I'm certain because
you guys have interviewed so many
writers but you know I think whether
it's easy for me or it's just something
I happen to subscribe to but I feel like
if you can create a character first that
and create a character in a certain
number of situations and not necessarily
and not necessarily outline the entire
movie although it depends on the movie
but if you have a full character that's
real that you've created and then you
put something in front of them in a way
they will begin to write the movie
because you know how they're going to
react
to whatever you put in front of them
because they're now these dimensional
characters as opposed to let's have this
happen let's have this happen let's add
this happen and we'll just make sure
that they do these things that I've you
know preordained and I think that's what
creates a feeling of artifice or you've
seen it all before or boring I think and
and so to me if you create a real
character then whatever happens as a
result of those characters interacting
is bound to be more interesting than
somebody something that's just been
constructed like I I was attached to a
big studio movie not too long ago and
the script was greenlit and everybody
loved it and I was reading this thing
and I was like I don't understand this
like and it says not a complicated movie
this was like a movie with Dinosaurs and
fighting and all that I'm reading this
thing and I'm like why is this guy dude
why is this guy doing this and I went to
the writer and I said you know what this
doesn't really make much sense you you
in the in the in the first act you
talked about how this guy was scared of
heights there was a whole dialogue about
he was scared of climbing the mountain
and then later he's like on a tightrope
fighting a terror attack or like wow wow
what's going on with that and he goes I
just thought that tiger thing was cool
and I was like yeah but it doesn't make
any sense you understand it's like you
know you set up this guy so there's got
to be you can't just put stuff in
because it's cool I mean people do it
all the time but as a director of this
thing uh I was looking at it like well
how am I supposed to direct this with
any kind of confidence or Authority if I
don't believe this thing and so I think
there's a lot of writing that's just
like well let's be cool this happens and
let's have this happen but that'd be
cool too and you have this pileup of
cool but that doesn't have any
resonance because it's not based in any
kind of reality or at least any kind of
consistency or something like that I
don't know if that makes sense but
that's that's something it does and so
Derek ters quote arc didn't didn't cross
over to the tightrope scene like was
there did the character go to a
fear-based weekend
why don't they just have him acknowledge
the fact that you know when it got to
the tightrope scene that he was still
scared but was overcoming you know what
it means like but it's almost this
negligence not even negligence is almost
like apathy like who cares whether it's
consistent who cares whether it makes
sense as long as it's cool and I think
the coolest movies that have the cool
this still are weighted or or or
rooted in some sort of reality that they
the writer has believed and has
maintained as opposed to just an
assembly of things that that that just
happened to be exciting but don't really
either trace back to something or
connect or make sense for the character
that's really what it is does it make
sense for the character would he do that
you know so like the example I always
give my students is that like if we're
walking along the street and all of a
sudden a mug or jumps out with a gun and
grabs your bag and runs and that's all
we have in terms of like that's the only
idea we could come up with in terms of
plot the next scene is if we know who we
are we know what's gonna happen like if
you for me like if the mugger pulls out
a gun I'll probably you know fall down
on the ground and cry and weep and hope
for it to be over on the other hand if I
had created like if you're you're a
former cop or you were in the war or any
ceil or whatever you know or somebody
who's like been you know mugged a couple
of times and now carries like brass
knuckles and mace whatever the deal
whatever you set up what happens as a
result of that mugger pulling the gun
and grabbing thing and running it's
either becomes a chase or it becomes us
going to a bar and crying together
whatever it is but you at least you know
or it's a fight or whatever it is but
you don't have to have the pressure of
okay and now I've got to come up with
the next thing now I've got to come up
with the next thing because if the
character is built then it will dictate
to you in a way what what will happen
which is actually less pressure on the
writer because now you don't have the
burden of having to make up every
goddamn thing the characters are in fact
writing the movie to a certain extent we
talk about having that dialogue test
where someone's just reading a character
and then people need to try to figure
out who's speaking and if your character
is authentic enough we should all know
you should be able to identify yeah
yeah in fact there are things like for
example they're worse in situations
where when my writing partner Jim and I
were first coming up with one of our
films lucu Karachi way back in the 90s
and one of the first images that came to
mind was this idea of a man in a
wheelchair in almost this True Grit sort
of scenario where he was like rolling
into this town like guns blazing in a
wheelchair that was the first idea in
Mexico we didn't even know how how it
got there but that was the image and I
was like holy that's amazing we got
to make this move we got to write this
we got to figure out and the irony was
by the time we had created really this
character and this scenario of his
writer who goes down to Mexico who's
really not a tough guy at all and
everything goes wrong by the time we got
to this finale which was the seed of the
whole thing as much as we wanted this
badass thing to happen it didn't make
any sense anymore it was like too big it
was it was out of character it didn't
make sense that this would happen he
wouldn't do this and we were kept trying
to like force ourselves into writing
this thing and it was like no it's not
going to be that because that's not
that's not true to the thing that we
actually wrote so I mean it depends on
your philosophy a studio is not gonna
give a about that so he's gonna say
put the wheelchair thing in
because that's awesome but a but a
writer with any kind of conscience is
gonna be like either go no that doesn't
work or they're gonna have to really
find a way to justify I always heard
that that that was Hitchcock's thing
that he would come up with a series of
set pieces sorry no that's okay I always
heard that Hitchcock basically came up
with a sequence of really cool set
pieces like I want to chase across the
faces of Mount Rushmore but I don't know
how it happens and then he would lay it
on the writer to somehow get you know I
want a Mount Rushmore thing I want a
crop-dusting thing that oh that'll be
awesome I want to stage those and shoot
those things I don't know how the hell
it happens and now it's your job you
know mr. and mrs. Ryder to figure out
how to make it make sense of course he
had the luxury of being able to do that
the writer still had to figure it out
though the writer still and when you
watch North by Northwest you look at it
and you're like wow that's a lot of like
effort to kill this guy really they're
gonna they're gonna bring him out to a
cornfield and they're gonna try to kill
him with a crop duster why doesn't
somebody just pop out and shoot the guy
in that in that easier the shouldn't
just be a sniper in the quote why is
there a crop duster well it's because
Hitchcock came up with this awesome idea
and there and the writer is just
basically going okay well if I maneuver
this enough maybe no one will notice
that it's insane so I don't know I guess
I guess it really does depend on the
philosophy of the writer her the
filmmaker how do you feel about the
quality of storytelling that you're
seeing in the world today I mean it's a
good question what do i how do I feel
about the quality of storytelling that's
a good question I don't know I'm not
really attracted to a lot of new stuff I
think because I've seen it before and
that's just my personal thing at this
point I I think it's just an age thing
and also it's a it's a result of being a
film nerd because when you consume as
much cinema as I have in my lifetime
you've you have seen in most cases the
best iterations of a particular story or
genre already so when I see something
new that just manages to be good
execution or well-executed version of a
story that I've already seen it's not
enough for me anymore so I don't you
know I find myself going back to the
films that have that really changed my
life that really did it best because I
want to be nourished in that way it's
not enough for me to see something
that's just a really good yarn that was
well directed and well produced even
though that's a monumental feat any
filmmaker will tell you you know that
making a good movie is a miracle but for
me personally I I tend to look to the
Past for the inspiration because I feel
like in most cases they it was done best
and and and that doesn't mean that I'm
I'm I'm I'm resistant to somebody
showing me something that's truly
brilliant because I would welcome that
if somebody showed me something that was
just earth-shatteringly brilliant that I
better than anything else then I would
be like Jesus Christ thank you you know
I want to see that stuff and I'm sure
it's out there I'm sure it's out there I
just
seen anything lately I know like The
Handmaid's Tale it was a movie with
right with McGovern right in the
eighties I think or the early 90s man uh
yeah that what do you mean the original
handmade still yeah yeah and so now now
it's like got a whole new life to it
right exactly yeah yeah and it's now
they're spoofing it on Saturday Night
Live right you know right but but back
then I don't remember if I really heard
a lot no no it's funny I actually I
think it was in the 80s I was actually
an intern at the production company
where they were making that movie
remember xeroxing and up the
Xeroxes I remember I think it was a
potato who was the director of that of
the original Handmaid's Tale I can't
believe I'm blanking on this German
director but anyway there was it was in
New York City I was like you know a PA
and the office and they were having this
special lunch meeting or something and I
was charged with getting the new draft
together and I was like you know just
put printing this thing out and whether
it was jammed in the print my ran over
to 21 or ever they were having dinner
and I remember giving it to the producer
and it was like all the pages were out
of order and everything he's looking at
me judgmentally I'm like I'm never gonna
work in this business yeah well a good
story I mean a good story that is that
that a filmmaker or writer finds a way
in that that changes it or makes it more
contemporary or more resonant or or
personal whatever it is I mean I think
that's that's totally valid too but I
just haven't seen much recently that's
like blown me away right I mean it's
kind of like you know a band that does
you know you know when the levee breaks
or something right like okay it sounded
so great when Robert Plant saying it but
now you're doing it it sounds good but
it just doesn't have the same value but
again is it a generational thing
because I know you and I were just
talking on write ever about video discs
and just seeing older like even 90s
terms that it just had a different feel
to it yeah well I think that's true I
mean I talked to my students about this
all the time I think it's a it's a it's
an amazing age and it's a horrible age
it's amazing in the sense that anything
you want to see from the history of the
world is available like
you know like that like gone are the
days of hunting for a revival house
that's going to be showing the third man
or Seven Samurai or what have you or
anything for that matter or the last
detail or whatever it is
it's not like you have to like hunt for
a video store now that they exist
anymore that's going to carry a special
John Woo Hong Kong action thing when
they can from like everything is
available at any given moment that said
there is so much material there's so
much available that I wouldn't know
where to begin
and I think that that's a problem
because unless there's somebody a
teacher or film geek parent or somebody
saying spend your time watching this
this this and this before you watch this
other stuff because that's going to
educate you that's going to make you a
better filmmaker then you're you're
bound to lose those great things and I'm
not even talking about like the obvious
classics I'm just talking about even
minor films that are still better than a
lot of junk that you see today you're
never going to see him then they're
never going to see them because there's
just too much to look at and so I'm sort
of losing the threat of the question but
I think Mike my feeling is is that
there's just almost too much to see now
and it'd be better if you I don't know
if someone helped me it's almost like
you you need to graduate you have to
like you there's a prerequisite but you
have to watch all this stuff if you're
gonna be a filmmaker and then you can
watch as much junk as you want that's
out now you know something like that
alright well a lot of stuff seems over
processed you know like two to two
overproduced yahweh's and maybe just as
a culture we've become used to that so
if it's not packaged that way yeah we
don't want it I think you're right I
think we were talking about this earlier
I think that if social media is
overproduced
in other words the somebody's personal
Instagram page with all its requisite
filters and yeah you know with this
glamour and and and the tools of
production in the hands of anybody and
it raises this level this this this
standard of what is acceptable
to a professional level in a certain way
but it also creates a certain artifice
as you know
one of my favorite quotes that John
Cassavetes said about Hollywood films in
general is that they're an advertisement
for life that's what he said because
Hollywood movies in most cases are an
advertisement for life and he was saying
whereas my films which are clearly
comparatively very rough and perhaps
even mistakenly looked upon as almost
amateurish compared to that polish and
mistakenly because that was by design by
him because he he was a professional but
he made his films look a certain way
because he was trying to get at
something that was the opposite that he
was trying to get at the messiness the
reality of life whereas Hollywood almost
by definition tries to minimize that in
favor of this gloss or polish or
illusion you know and so yeah I think
that becomes this the diet that you're
consuming then if you see something
that's grittier or Messier or and I'm
not even talking about the look I'm
talking about the content where the
content is not just this clearly safe
define thing people may have a
resistance to that they may go whoa
this is not I don't want this this is
too much this is not when I'm you know
this is not the food I've chosen to eat
but what does it do to your tastes you
know it limits your tastes to only want
this candy and not something that's more
substituted for what's the right word
substantial in that way you know it's
nourishing I was just watching part of
the Stepford Wives which 100 the the
original and yeah and just how you know
they're like the long driving sequence
game with all the credits and the
classic like you know was it 70s yeah
okay track you know at the time that we
would hear all the time and now it
sounds so wonderful but at the time
every show and movie had it that's right
but you know just how it was so quiet of
in terms of there's there's just moments
where it's it's not like something's
happening every second right right
reading yeah and I think that's that's
actually you know I've always said this
and anybody will tell you this that the
strength of a spike in a store
our movie where something goes crazy
where there's a lot of kinetic activity
or surprise or whatever is directly
related to the quiet that precedes it in
other words something is super loud or
big relative to what preceded it so
that's why in a horror movie and then
you know they learn this going all the
way back to the 30s but if you if you
have a very quiet almost nothing
happening and then a huge scare that
scare becomes magnified whereas if you
have to maintain what is now you know
the classic Hollywood mantra of just a
thrill every second then each then that
thrill every second becomes a plateau
you just become accustomed to it it's
not going to it's not going to hit you
the same way if you allowed for that
quiet to precede it but that assumes
that the audience or probably assume
that assumes that the producers are
willing to allow that quiet to happen
and not be kosher people are going to be
bored we got to do something exciting
and you can be have this length of quiet
and that the audiences are willing to
invest in that and be okay with that and
say this is not boring this is
interesting and then be the beneficiary
of the result of that if something huge
follows it because it'll be huger you
know because of it
I was watching a documentary on Mary
Shelley yeah and it was saying that you
know first off I know she had to sort of
publish the story anonymously because
they didn't think a woman could write it
but also her age factored in and I was
wondering do you think that age factors
into creating meaningful work mm-hmm
I don't think age I don't think age is
an issue if somebody has experienced
something that is worth communicating I
mean I think that it all it's all based
on how much you have inside of you at
the time that you're creating this stuff
so there are plenty of young people who
have had tremendously rich dramatic even
traumatic experiences that are perfectly
positioned to do something magical with
that life experience I think the problem
comes when you don't have enough life
experience you don't have anything to
say you know that's the problem I can't
remember which filmmaker it was who said
when he graduated from film school he
said everybody was just scrambling to
try to make their first feature and he
said I'm gonna take like I'm gonna take
five years off and I'm gonna like live
some and live I don't know but I'm gonna
live my life because he even then knew
that he didn't have anything to say that
was worth saying yet so I think that's
probably a problem with a lot of
filmmakers is that you know if they
don't constantly inform their work with
what's going on or if their lives don't
don't aren't enriched by their by
certain experiences they ended up just
that's the classic going up your own ass
thing where you just you know you're not
really saying anything new you're just
repeating so I think that's that's
what's most important is what is the
what is informing the work not
necessarily at the age and obviously
Mary Shelley was perfectly and it was in
a position had plenty to say on the
subject and knocked it out so it didn't
it didn't really matter I mean or an
Orson Welles is obviously the you know
the the prime example of 20 you know
somebody in his middle 20s you know
doing the ultimate commentary on a on an
old on an old shattered man's life you
know that that's the that's pretty
pretty amazing when someone have would
have that perspective so I guess it
depends on the individuals
but I think a lot of people think that
their life and everybody's life is
unique oh well I've had these tragedies
even though one is a different set of
tragedy and the other they're equally
painful to the person experiencing it
but don't you think that people
everybody thinks they have something to
say at 18 at 22 oh I think so and some
really do and maybe some need to go out
and I think so I think it depends on the
person I I think that I think everybody
thinks that they're I mean look
everybody's everybody's life at any
given moment is valid and dramatic the
question does that translate into a into
a movie you know and what you know
obviously Truffaut with 400 blows you
knows a perfect or even you look at Rob
Reiner doing stand by me I mean if you
nail it then you can you can paint a
picture of the drama and the complexity
of being you know an adolescent you know
you can that can be infinitely dramatic
if you if you get it if you get it right
so it's not like a child's life is
invalid or I was just talking about the
red balloon the other day and you know
the red balloon is one of those movies
where when I was in college everyone was
saying oh he got to see the bright blue
and I'm like I don't want to see a movie
about a little kid in this magical
balloon that's like you know who cares I
want to see you know real gritty and
finally I sat down and watched the red
balloon when I was like you know 21 I'm
good because it it perfectly captured
that feeling of being you know seven
years old and alone and everybody hates
you and particularly if you're bullied
and it just nailed so I it depends on
the it depends on the story and the
person who's telling it everybody's life
is valid it's just a question is that
does that translate into a 90 minute
movie that anybody's gonna watch you
know I know we were having a
conversation before we got going about
the competition online and how hard it
is to you know get people to see your
work right where do you stand on
creating things that audiences want to
see and maybe willing to pay for versus
creating work that's meaningful to you
right and maybe it's gonna just be a
little niche audience right well I don't
think I've ever been any good at
thinking in terms of let me craft
something that's going to be
a big audience favorite because I think
that it's hard enough for the filmmaker
or for me to get interested in a
particular story anyway in other words I
never felt that I was even though I can
execute any story and I have done
television and I've done things that
were scripted I can I can make that
movie and I can make it hopefully work
to set out to make a film that story has
to be meaningful personally otherwise I
won't have the strength to to go through
the obstacles and all the knows and it's
not going to there has to be something
driving that for me personally so and I
never thought I was necessarily skilled
as an architect of that kind of audience
crowd-pleasing
super commercial movie I just hope that
because I do love commercial cinema
there's plenty of commercial movies that
I love that somehow by that love will
find its way into whatever story I'm -
I'm doing and they will contain those
elements but hopefully will be more
personal they won't be as machined so
yeah I you know I'd probably be more I'd
probably be a wealthy man if I was you
know skilled in that you know in that
but I think the best people who do make
commercial movies and you can just
rattle me know what going all the way
back to Spielberg or Michael Bay those
people that do make those movies they
are that's that's how they think in
other words it's not like I don't think
they're sitting around saying let's you
know make a commercial movie that maybe
on their mind but their tastes are
exactly that commercial thing so it just
happens that right the audience of
course is going to connect because they
are that audience and that's they're the
perfect they're the perfect people to
make that stuff otherwise everybody
would be able to do that if it was
simply a matter of like reading the
instructions on how to make then
everybody would just go yeah I want to
be rich let's just do that and and it's
it's not for lack of trying everybody
tries a lot of people try but for me I
have to find I have to find a story that
is valuable in some way to me
and then I can I'm happy to add on all
the quote unquote commercial components
or exploitative components or any of
those things that you find in a
commercial movie but at least the
foundation is is personal thinking of a
movie like um people maybe people
disagree with me but into the wild right
those about Christopher McCandless is
story and I hadn't really heard of the
book before the movie came out right
when I didn't realize there was like
this whole cult following for this book
but that's one that it seems like you
wouldn't expect the audience to resident
even though I think it's a fantastic
film right and I loved it but but it's a
store it's a very special story that's
right you wouldn't it's not about you
know an everyday thing but but somehow I
was able to resonate with millions of
people right well I think I think you're
right because I think it's probably
because the specific then the nature of
the story about somebody based putting
themselves out into the into the
wilderness to that extreme it's not the
specific act that everybody can relate
to I think it's the internal thing that
the person is going through that people
connect with that's what I'm talking
about I mean there's something Universal
in those kinds of feelings and I think
that's why for example they always talk
you know everybody involved with taxi
driver said this isn't you know we're
making this for us but probably no one's
gonna get it and then it turned out to
be this huge hit because there were as a
billion very alienated lonely angry
individuals out there that went oh my
god that's you know I identify with that
so I think we'd be a lot richer Phil
mcli if the business allowed for more of
those movies to be made because you know
a producer is not going to you know is
not is going to be looking for something
that is obviously something that people
can relate to but but people are much
more complicated than than than the way
they're depicted in Hollywood movies and
so every once in a while when something
presents a reflection of that it's out
there I think it will be successful
because people like thank you thank you
for showing you know showing me that I
am represented as opposed to it just
being
you know a cartoon or again an
advertisement for life so even something
like Legally Blonde which is a it's a
cute story and there's a great message
in and I enjoyed the film uh-huh
but it makes light of someone that's
sort of ostracized right and in real
life someone probably wouldn't be well
I'm just gonna you know get all dolled
up and go in there and show them it's
gonna be you know a lot of pain behind
the scenes but it's definitely showing
something that many people have been
through right but in a light way where I
feel safe well that's that mean and
that's bound to be the more commercial I
mean if you can somehow illustrate those
really painful awkward things in a way
that manages to be entertaining or safe
which i think is a really good word
because most people go to the movies as
a they go to the movies they take it
like a tonic they're not they're not
going to be unless you're going to a
torture porn you know you're not going
to be ripped apart you're going to be
soothed
so camouflaging or or sugarcoating or I
don't know how you put it real things in
a Hollywood way I think is a real that's
a real art and a real trick and if that
can happen you know like for example
like for me like I resisted Groundhog
Day
like when Groundhog Day came out I was
like this is just a one-note thing I
think most people thought that how this
guy wakes up every day huh and then when
you actually watched the movie and you
know Harold Ramis does this bring Bill
Murray do this brilliant job of getting
at a lot of real deep things in this
very silly gimmicky movie and that was
obviously their intent you know that
that dealing with somebody who was
bitter and it given up and doesn't give
a about people anymore and has
disconnected and just a user and then
through this this twist of fate now has
to like go through the stages of
processing that totally becomes like a
human being you know if you'd made a
straightforward movie about that without
the gimmick I don't think it would be
that as popular necessarily people
wouldn't go to see it but with the twist
and the comedy I'm say that again but
with the twist and the comedy and the
Bill Murray aspect the whole thing it
becomes this much more pleasurable
pill the swallow and a surprise in a way
and that's why it like I love that movie
because it's lame wow I thought this was
this superficial shitty thing and it
turns out to be actually a quite complex
interesting movie and I love that I mean
I and there are times where I want my
message or my identification in a nice
candy package we don't always want it
you know ruff do you have any creative
regrets like a film idea not followed
well I think my biggest regret would be
not making the movie I'm trying to make
right now I mean search and rescue is a
movie that's like been percolating for
at least seven or eight years if not
longer it's a movie that I I feel like I
should have made a long time ago but I
was sort of not sort of I was scared for
a lot of reasons I didn't think I didn't
think I could handle another
disappointment if it didn't happen
because obviously anybody has been you
know like John but I remember I heard
John Boorman say something once it was
really interesting and I totally got it
he said he said in a very bitter moment
he said this business is all about the
movies you didn't get to make and I was
like really you made like a lot of
really cool you mean deliverance in
Excalibur and all the help and glory
you're being better but for every
filmmaker there are all those pictures
that didn't happen which is the nature
of the thing but in the case of search
and rescue that's a movie that I always
knew was going to be independent I knew
that the movie couldn't really be
produced
traditionally anyway which is perfect
because I so fed up with the way
Hollywood works anyway and and and I
realized that this was something that I
had to do truly independently but it
took me a while to muster up the courage
to to do it and so I think my biggest
regret would be if I didn't follow
through with this movie which now we're
in the you know in the early early
stages of it but that's that's that's my
I don't think it's a fear it's just I
it's put you know my I'm pushing myself
from behind to make this thing happen so
I don't have those regrets why now
though
I think it's you know I think it goes
back to to what you were talking about
about where I am timing-wise
in my life I mean I feel like this is
the right time for me to make this kind
of movie for me I just reached a stage
and it's been several years now where I
felt like the movies I were I was making
for hire just were not it just wasn't
just didn't sit right with me and just I
felt like I was spinning wheels or worse
wasting my time I just felt like yeah I
can make a shitty sci-fi movie but
that's what it is and it does you know
I've said this I think we talked about
this before I think all filmmakers are
our heroin addicts in a way not
literally ill to summer in the sense
that your junkie for just a just the
process of making a film so it's hard
enough to get anything made so even if
somebody says we're gonna offer you
three bucks to make a movie for a sci-fi
channel do you want to do it my first
instinct was always like yes because it
was that needle in the arm like we can
make a movie but the the box that those
movies gets gets made and only allows
for a certain type of movie to result no
matter what you do I always have this
delusion that I'm gonna bring I'll be
able to bring something more tanned then
what is usually expected of you know a
low blow a low-budget exploitation movie
and in the end there may be little hits
here and there of individuality and
maybe a pinch more intelligence but in
the end it is what it is so then you
spent an enormous amount of time and
energy on something that is essentially
inconsequential unless unless I was
happy being that but I always felt like
I was wrestling with
identity issues like what did I want to
be did I want to be a professional
Hollywood director and did I want that
or did I also want to be somebody who
made movies that matter to me personally
and I when I when I really did the math
and I looked at the different films that
I've had the good fortune to be able to
make over the years you know good or bad
I looked at him and I go and you know I
was most satisfied when I was making I
was most myself when I was making these
really small movies where I didn't
really have to deal with the of
Hollywood or people telling me to recut
it or cut this storyline or or put this
music in or whatever and nobody monkeyed
with it and even though I wasn't getting
paid anything sometimes that was where I
felt like I was at home creatively so
you know I got to a point where I felt
like this is where this is where I need
to be if I'm gonna be honest with myself
or I can keep pulling myself in these
different directions and allowing myself
to say yeah if I make this other thing
you know it's just it's okay it's good
you know but there was a part of me that
was telling me you know you you kind of
got to go back to your early ideas your
early films and that's where you were
happiest right I did have a really good
spike with some guy who kills people
that was like an accident
you know where this light present
dropped out of the sky the timing was
just you know was just like one of those
things where if you stay at the
slot-machine long enough something good
will happen
well something managed to drop that I
happened to connect with and that was
like I was a super lucky to get that job
but I didn't create that you know what I
mean I didn't I didn't self create that
that was just it was just really perfect
timing and I you can't I can't allow
myself to just hope that and something
else is gonna drop from the sky I kind
of got to put it on the line and make
the thing myself you know we talked
about the addiction part and and you
know I've probably mentioned this a
gazillion times in film courage
interviews but um it's it's the subject
of like your levels are blown out so so
the filmmaker
younger he made Restrepo with tethering
right and he talked about men that go to
battle yet sometimes they keep going
back because going to the family
barbecue like the level of the
adrenaline rush that your I used to is
no longer their laps your levels are
blown out so I would imagine that's
similar for someone who's been on stage
doing stand-up or music and filmmaking
as well I agree I think that it's like
you know you've gotten this taste of a
certain energy when you make a film even
if you've only made one film even if
you've just made a short you know I tell
this to my students if you make a
student film and you get this rush that
you've never felt before and you really
want that rush again and that's what
motivates you then you know you're a
real filmmaker and if you can get that
rush anywhere else then please do it
because it's so much easier so I think
that when you've made a few films and
you know what that high is then you
crave that high and it's very difficult
to just be satisfied with not making a
film I mean I think that's really what
it boils down to it's like most
filmmakers are not satisfied when
they're not making a film so you spend a
lot of time in between hustling to try
to find a way to get to that that high
again just like a soldier who you know
mysteriously - it - and I'm objectively
it sounds crazy like why would you want
to go back but even if you listen to the
opening of Apocalypse Now the narration
is that you know as that stuff when I
was you know when I was here I wanted to
be there when I was home all I wanted to
be was back in the jungle you know and
it's that sort of like you're it's a
heavy attraction or addiction so you put
together the crowdfunding campaign video
right for rescue
it's excellent by the way thank you from
part of the movie in the beginning right
yeah we actually shot a standalone I
guess teaser for the movie it's funny
because the you know the the the the
teaser in the in the campaign is not
actually a scene from the movie when I
really tried to some people try to like
cobble together moments from the actual
movie the main character Kevin Corrigan
is definitely the main character but I
was trying to find something that would
represent sort of the tone
of the movie not only visually but also
sort of the black comic component so
it's a violent movie and it has a
certain degree of black comedy in it not
unlike some guy who kills people and I
wanted to kind of do something that
would just say that very quickly so I
realized I could write something
separately that would represent it so
that's the whole trophy hunt you know
beating the out of the trophy
hunter came from that although now that
I think about it I'm now thinking of
actually incorporating this idea
somewhere in the story so that maybe it
could even work as like a post credit
sequence like somewhere in the movie
almost outside of the plot there's this
trophy hunter thing so that the end of
the picture he beats the out of the
trophy owner almost like a bonus you
know but yeah that's where that that's
where that came from so then you have
another part of the video where then you
introduce the campaign right and then
you show behind the scenes footage of
you on set with at least one or two
different productions that's right
that's right
and I enjoyed watching both it's almost
like there are two separate things in
one which is helpful yeah um when you
watch that footage of yourself directing
is that someone you know right there I
mean can you believe that like wow
that's me because you almost have to
become a different person I'm sure when
you're rounding how do you feel seeing
that that footage and this is gonna I'm
sorry I'm taking a drink here oh that's
okay you jump cut these are sure sure
yeah well when I look at myself in
behind the scenes footage I do recognise
myself in it but as you as you mentioned
it's it's me and set mode like for
example I had some students that
assisted in the production of the of the
teaser and they only know me from class
they know me from my lectures and how I
and when I'm in class I wear you know
suit jacket and I'm you know and I'm a
bit of a germaphobe so I'm like you know
constantly you know like you know doing
this kind of stuff
very neurotically and I you know and
they observed when when we were shooting
there's like wow you're you're totally
different because now I'm in a t-shirt
I'm rolling around on the floor trying
to show Kevin Corrigan how to get hit
and all this stuff and I'm not conscious
it's a different it's a different head
it's a totally different head you're
just you're in shooting mode you're in
and what I tell my students is that
you know to be a good director you have
to really disappear into whatever you're
making you have to be so in the moment
it's not like you're just executing IKEA
instructions which are the script you
know that's the mistake it's like well
if I just follow the script and I build
this shelf
that'll be it's not that at all it's
like this it's this this thing that the
director has to do which is sort of Wed
with the material like or it just has to
become real absolutely real so you can't
have any you can't be self-conscious at
all about how you look or you're just in
this in the in the making of the piece
so in the reality of the piece so I
think what I notice when I watch footage
of myself is how in that head I am like
just doing it which I love you know
again it's it's what all filmmakers
crave is to get to that place where you
can just like play and there is a real
correlation I also save this in class
it's like you know if you can remember
when you're a little kid and you're
playing with dolls or cars or are and
maybe we've said this before but it's
like you're never like self-conscious
about that you're just like in it you
know you're inside both of the you know
and that's the way I like to be when I'm
making a film you're just inside this
thing that's actually happening as
opposed to now we do this so now we do
that you know it's not a cold process
it's a very little alive you know
messy thing right anything could happen
anything I have yeah so now you're
you're looking to make this film has it
all been shot or no you know no no no we
just shot the teaser okay you know we we
shot the teaser I was able to get you
know Kevin Corrigan to come out from New
York to do the teaser and Lucy Davis
who's also in the movie originally when
I wrote the teaser or she was actually
going to appear in the scene with the
final kut'rs kind of sort of pop out of
the corner and do this final sort of you
know jab at the trophy hunter but she's
been shooting the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina in Vancouver for like six months
and she can't get away
so I contrived this whole idea of this
face time thing so she's shot so we I
directed her over the phone and she
actually shot that that piece up in
Vancouver
then you know I shot a plate and that's
how we put her into the picture but yeah
we just shot this as really a sample to
say this is the kind of movie we're
making this is not just an abstraction
this is these are the actors this is the
look this is the tone and and now we're
just going to you know roughly raise the
money so we can make the whole thing why
not make a documentary I'm just gonna
play the devil's advocate here so if you
in and I know the word message is not
like but if for those of us who feel
strongly about animals and I am one of
the people and and I know trophy hunting
has gotten a lot of light the dark light
on it yeah rightfully so
without going too much into it yeah but
why not make a documentary that's a good
question I mean I think that if I was a
documentary filmmaker I'd make a
documentary on animal compassion or how
animals are systematically brutalized
and factory farming and so forth I I
would make that documentary but I think
those documentaries thankfully exist or
and more of them are being made and up
to now that has been the way to reach
people about animal rights I think a
really good documentary that illustrates
life on a factory farm or animal testing
any of those things or fur farms or
anything where animals are routinely
abused a documentary that shows you
what's going on is a real eye-opener and
absolutely necessary but I'm a narrative
filmmaker and in many ways I'm so
ridiculously sensitive to to what goes
on with animals in those situations that
I can't even watch I can't even watch
those images I mean I know what they are
I saw I saw that material which is in
many ways what made me become a
vegetarian and ultimately a vegan I saw
what was going on but I can't watch that
again and I can't watch it certainly as
an entertainment so for me making a
narrative in this case a crime thriller
that has a lot of animal rights themes
baked into it was the best way for me to
communicate
my feelings on the subject as opposed to
a documentary because I am a filmmaker a
narrative filmmaker I love genre I love
crime thrillers and thrillers I love
atmosphere and I want to make the movie
that I would want to see that would get
this point across without driving me
from the theater crying although I do
think that stuff is necessary so we
talked earlier about like how do you how
do you put this not not that Legally
Blonde is the comparison but but but you
brought it up which is that how do you
get this message across in a way that's
I wouldn't say it's safe but it's
definitely more watchable than you know
going into an abattoir you know with a
video camera so I think that's the best
way for me to to get my point across
isn't this in this format you know it's
interesting that you even though you
you've dedicated your life and your
lifestyle to compassion for animals yeah
not being able to watch certain things
in and I'm the same way I saw something
interesting out in the public space and
I won't even say where it is because I
don't want these people to get in
trouble yeah I want them to keep doing
it yeah but they were holding these
screens so the video monitors yes and
they are showing oh they're amazing
okay so okay so yeah we're talking about
this no no yeah and I I and people I
could tell were scared and I was scared
to see but I was like fascinated about
what they were doing no that's that that
movement is incredible basically you
know it's it's it's it's a real hardcore
way but again a necessary way of saying
okay look you know this is your meet you
know meet your meat as they used to as
the expression used to go it's like
check it out this is what happens yeah
and you know these people gather in huge
public places and they have these
screens and often times they're you know
we're an anonymous anonymous mask right
and you see people for the first time
seeing what the truth of this stuff is
and they they are rightfully you know
justifiably destroyed and hopefully
cannot unsee that you know I mean the
the expression if you know if all if
slaughterhouses were made a class we'd
all be vegetarian is a true statement
there's a reason why that world is is
socked away
side of the public eye and why meat and
eggs and all that stuff remains just a
product safely packaged without any of
the pain that that that that is the
origin of that stuff because if you saw
it you'd be like I'm not gonna eat
that so those people are really you know
that's the real work where you're like
okay you know this is the truth you want
it you know and I think they're changing
a lot of people's minds you know bit by
bit well not only that but if you're
isn't it a terrorist offense to consider
it an act of terrorism to film with in
one of those places I'm gonna you know
that's a good question I just know that
the people who actually liberate animals
I mean people like that are part of
Animal Liberation Front an organ owned
unoffensive animal organizations that
basically take direct action and go into
a fur farm or a factory farm and either
damage the property but more importantly
rescue the animals that are either going
to be experimented on or killed
they are definitely branded as
terrorists even though they never hurt
people it's strictly it's a business
thing it's amazing to see how corporate
how that kind of money is able to I mean
it's the history of the world influence
you know policy so that these people you
know do serious jail time and you know
and they haven't heard anybody if
anything they've they've wrecked some
they've destruction of public property
or private property and they've saved
animals but that they'll do hard time
for that you know that's crazy
so 10 years ago I believe you visited
the cathouse on Kings
yeah the cathouse on the Kings yeah on
the Kings sorry and so how did this have
this wonderful sanctuary to change your
life oh it was huge it was like we know
we talked about this and we had a feral
cat we've always had feral cats come to
our house because we have lots of cats
and a feral cat a wild cat will will
just sense that cat people lived there
and a feral cat obviously cannot be pet
or touched or anything they're they're
wild animals but we've done this over
the years and we fed feral cats so you
know I guess it's a little over 10 years
ago we were moving from our apartment
and just as we were about to move a
feral cat showed up and it was like feed
me and we were like yes of course we'll
feed you but we're moving and it we were
faced suddenly but this prospect of like
what are we gonna do this this this
animal is like dependent upon us now but
we're moving it got to the point where I
was like literally driving across town
every day to leave food is this empty
house the cat was standing it was the
saddest thing to use he's like where's
my food I'm like I'm driving across town
we I said can't keep this up I can't
expect into new tenants to take care of
him or whatever so I started looking
into rescues and looking into that whole
world and it's a you know it did again I
became educated was like wow there's
just there's just tons of kill shelters
if you bring an animal to a regular
shelter likely they will be killed
certainly a feral who can never be
adopted rarely what do you do with a
feral cat and so after a lot of research
I found this one place which I had never
heard of the cat house on the king´s
which was this one woman's massive
property up near Fresno that she had
turned in this ranch-style multi acre
property into this sanctuary an adoption
center where she had you know almost a
thousand animals that were totally cared
for it wasn't an I wasn't a hoarder it
was like an operation sure and she was
like yeah you know we actually have a
feral you know section and if you can
catch him you know you can bring him
here and I was like wow and where Oliver
everybody else was like we're full up
and they'll kill him and all this was
the one place I went to when I went up
there it was like one woman and a couple
of men maybe one other person and all of
these animals and I was
like this was like the definition to me
of like a saint like this was like this
woman who had dedicated her whole life
to these animals literally and was like
making it work she she definitely needed
help but and I said to myself my god
well what what can I do in exchange for
this you know you save this cat's life
and these thousands of other dogs and
cats so I decided to make this YouTube
video I said I'll come back and I'll do
a portrait of you and the place a couple
minutes and you know we'll put it on
YouTube and this is when YouTube was
sort of new you know and and it just we
just as luck would have it there were
enough cat people out there that it
started to go viral and people really
saw that this was a this beautiful soul
that was doing something so unique and
she started to get donations and it
started to get more well-known and now
you know 10 13 years later it's a it's a
it's considered you know it's a very
well-known institution you know around
the world people come from all over the
world to visit this place and support
support it so it's a big part of
search-and-rescue story the ending of
the whole movie actually happens at the
cat house it actually takes place at the
cat house and I'm trying to talk Linnea
Lattanzi oh the the proprietor into
actually playing herself in the movie if
she'll agree to do it because he's such
a character
but yeah the whole movie actually
resolves at the cat house have you
thought about what would have happened
if you had moved one week earlier and
never met that yeah I know I hadn't
really thought of that it's been such a
you know my wife has said you know it's
the most important film you ever made
was that film for the cat house because
you know talking about direct action
that film because it went viral because
I made it because it exists and it
reached people that that institution
that sanctuary received much-needed
donations that saved a lot more animals
and so in terms of doing something
that's valuable truly valuable that
little film you know when I think about
it you know is you know definitely up
there as being
important movie of mine just because it
helped it ultimately helped a lot of
animals do you know how many views that
video has well I I think you know I
think now it's you know it's well over a
million views but it but it yeah you
know like but conversely you know like I
did this you know fun monster thing for
YouTube years ago your force five that
has 50 million views now oh wow okay but
the million and a half or whatever that
the cat house is way more valuable
because that that just means something
and read in real world terms you know
there are a lot of animals that got
saved because people gave because they
saw the video so yeah I'm I don't I
don't know what would happen certainly
search-and-rescue wouldn't have evolved
the way it did because my there's a
there's a cat component and there's a
feral component and a rescue component
to the story that is that is a threat in
this crime story that is the direct
result of my experience with with the
cat house on the king´s and why I feel
it's appropriate to end the movie there
even though there's gangsters and
assassins and pornographers and all this
other stuff in the movie it ultimately
ends at the cat house you know which is
like the sweetest place on earth it's
interesting too that you say just a
million views I mean that is almost
impossible so these days so going back
to writing or creating something to the
audience you think the audience once you
were just doing this because you wanted
to get people to know about that's it
yeah a million is still I mean that's I
don't there's it's absolutely huge I
think it has to do with what's behind
the thing why it doesn't really matter
because it's so random I like to think
that if the thing that you're making
it's the thing that you're making has
real meaning or so it's as real meaning
beyond like I just want it to be
successful like they're plenty of people
who make that just want to be rich
and famous and then there are other
people who make things that there's
another reason behind it there's
something real behind it that hopefully
like the truth will
out that somehow that will smell like
the real thing in people and talking
from them from a from a web-based thing
that maybe people will be attracted to
that thing because it's real as opposed
to opposed but that's not necessarily
true because there's plenty of stupid
insignificant that has trillions of
hits so I mean that's you know that's
that's my you know that's me one wanting
some sort of justice in the universe or
some sort of rationale but I do think in
the case of the cat on the Kings I think
people did respond to like the sincerity
of that place you know it's like the
it's like line is talking about the
sincerity of the pumpkin patch you know
there's something sincere so no
just like this woman is like this is why
she's doing it there's no ulterior
motive is nothing and when you see that
it's hard to say like it's hard not to
go Jesus let's let's help this person
you know so yeah very meaningful to just
accidentally be be brought into that to
the cat house because it changed you
know the way I think about a lot of
things it's interesting for people who
have rescued animals yeah these
different moments where these animals
have either come to you or that animal
led you to something else and I think
everybody can probably attest to that oh
definitely you know having had my own
rescues come through my door and
different things that happened you know
like one of them I gotten in a minor car
accident but I had to get my car fixed
and then there's a cat right so I would
have never had that cat which I ended up
happening for 15 years right
had it not been for me and it was a
drunk driver and I you know had to go
and pay for it myself but going to that
you know mechanic and then like Oh whose
kitten is that in the road you know and
then writing it so different things like
that for those of us who have absolutely
I think you're right and I think there's
a it's different from like when you plan
a family or something you know like you
you planned out you plan to have a baby
and then you try to have the baby and
you have the baby and you raise the bay
that's a different thing for animal
people where in most cases these
incredibly important members of your
family kind of happen in this
happenstance kind of way you know like
you said like it could just accidentally
you were in this place at this time and
now this animals come
to your life and now that animal is like
inseparable from your life and it's and
and as meaningful as any human child
would be you know and that's another
thing that's hard to explain you know
people get very defensive yeah how could
an animal would be like well they are I
mean an animal people will tell you and
when they die it's like you know it's as
its as traumatic it's as powerful as
when a human being dies so but I do
think it's interesting that that these
key figures in your life sometimes just
come out of nowhere you know not planned
right yeah I've stopped arguing with
people I had I was at the vet with a cat
and a man stopped and I thought I was
gonna remark on how adorable the cat was
but instead he just wanted to argue and
say why do you treat this animal like
it's so great and I was like yeah okay
how much time I give this for right you
don't know yeah you can't you can't keep
so impossible to explain to somebody who
do doesn't know you know but those who
know know right right so that's a nice
you know and and the same thing about
arguing vegetarianism or what's wrong I
just I just don't I find people want to
argue it with me and that's fine but I I
don't
I'm not they're trying to yeah anyway
yeah absolutely and also you know food
it's so interesting people take food
very personally food is such a personal
thing it's not just this it's so wrapped
up in people's histories and their
families and it's almost like religion
and so you can't something you can't
challenge them but it's going to lead
people get very you know like protective
about that kind of stuff and I think
that you know all you can hopefully do
is you know not know not necessarily
judge but if you just you know if you
judge somebody that's one way of doing
it another way of doing is sort of
talking people into being open to like
opening themselves to the information at
least have the information because if
you have the information then you are
the kind of person that feels that they
can make a choice and Andy's suffering
by not eating certain meats or to do
certain foods then they will do it and I
think there's this huge explosion in the
last this the last couple of years of
veganism and vegetarianism that that you
haven't seen
all over the world I mean it's just just
in and just interrupts the foods that
are available now this look like
something like the impossible burger
which is everywhere you know you can buy
you know beyond burger at Vons you know
so we're you weren't able to find you
know vegan food it's everywhere now you
know so it's hopeful alright it's
interesting that you say that about how
food there's a lot of issues around I
know I'm not a gluten-free person but I
know there are certain people I've met
that man if they find out someone
there's a gluten-free person they just
they want to back it up with all this
scientific research out they should it's
it's all you know nonsense and right
okay that's the person's choice let them
have it
whether you know pasilla silly yeah it's
like religion again it's like you're
like it's not enough for you to believe
what you believe you must destroy the
other person's belief that's why it has
that it's that's why food does have that
weird sort of quality which makes it a
very delicate subject but you know
that's why it takes all kinds you know I
think the direct action people who show
screens of slaughterhouses I mean that's
that's the most in your face kind of
stuff that you can do in terms of
raising awareness you know what I'm
trying to do is sort of couch it in an
entertainment because I think that's a
way that's another way of reaching
people you know maybe it's a
subversively
a way of reaching people you know but
you know however the information comes
across is good what are your first steps
in the screenwriting process I think the
first steps when I when I begin to write
is a lot of thinking about thinking
about it like I don't I'm not really
good at just sitting down and starting
to bang it out and I don't really often
times I don't write an outline it's not
like I have to make an outline first and
then write the script so for me usually
it's a couple of ideas that just won't
go away and so if those ideas won't go
away then that means that there's
something hopefully there's something
there and I just let it percolate and it
has a sort of magnetic if it's a good
idea and these are rare because it's not
like I have like never been one of those
guys that just like
you know I was able to spin a good yarn
and have a million stories I want to
tell but in the case of
search-and-rescue it was just a couple
of ideas started to sort of bind
together and I think some of them were
ideas that I had for other movies that
didn't go anywhere like in other words
they were deaths and it's now that I
think about it they were there were
several different ideas and characters
that had been I had been developing for
other movies that didn't sustain
themselves they were good but they
didn't for some reason they didn't
belong in whatever movie I was think I
was trying to make and so it all started
to kind of combine into this one film
but you know what I you know that's
specific to this particular movie and
every writing every writing process is
different you know if somebody comes to
me and says I need you to write
megashark versus giant octopus in two
weeks that's a different that's a
different process that's when you sit
down and you know figure out you know
okay act one this session happened this
show you know that's when I do that so
so you know work-for-hire that has to be
of a you know I think that's easier a
simpler genre is easier to do than this
but I really didn't have to think about
it and I really did have to draw from a
lot of things that had been dormant
ideas that had been dormant that sort of
all sort of coalesced to form this thing
that's how it started then I didn't then
of course I had to sit down and write
everyday like everybody else you have to
write it you know you can think about it
all day long but you have to write it
did you have dedicated time stuff I did
I just I finally you know I kept talking
about it and my wife was finally like
you need to write this thing you just
need to do it you know and with
certainly without Valerie's you know
insisting that I just you know get down
to it I probably wouldn't have done it
but I did I just basically realized that
if I got up at you know 5:00 in the
morning
every day that I would be in this kind
of you know a lot of writers talk about
that this is this kind of like haze well
you're not really judging you're not in
a critical mind you're just sort of in a
semi dream state that if I got up at
5:00 and wrote for like till 9:00 or
something like that
you know if I wrote for three or four
hours in the morning that I could bang
out you know without me judging myself I
would just
you know four pages or three or four or
five it was a good day
and I just did that you know over you
know however long it was a month
I just just everyday just knocked out a
little bit so at least you know after if
you do the math I mean five pages a day
at times twenty days what honored pages
so in with inside of a month you can get
a draft done and then you go back and
you're like oh this is and this
doesn't work and you actually are able
to tackle it critically but at least the
hard part of just getting it out was
accomplished if I was diligent and got
up and just did it and that's hard you
know it's like going to the gym or
whatever it's not that that takes you
know anybody will tell you that's and
some days you don't have anything
sometimes you just sit there you know
and you're just like you know I got one
line but I think as all writers or real
writers will tell you that's like what's
necessary the writer writes you can't
expect to just not do it and then have
great stuff pour out you have to go to
the gym you know so that's how it that's
how it happened you said something
earlier about you have a friend who's a
real writer writer and I was just
wondering how how is that different how
what is a real writer writer I think a
real writer writer is someone who just
writes all the time like that's what
they do it's not even about like making
physically making the movie it's about
writing it's like they write one script
and then they start working on the next
script or they write one novel and
they're already outlining the next novel
they just what I considered
dyed-in-the-wool
writers the way that are not - it you
know writer directors or whatever
they're just writers and I have real
respect for that because you know it's
like it's very myopic it's like this is
their skill you know and it's a very
difficult thing to be a good writer so I
have a lot of respect for that you know
I I'm a writer I don't think I'm a
writer naturally I'm a writer out of
necessity in other words I became a
writer because I couldn't expect
screenplays to fall out of the sky for
me to direct so I became a writer so I
could have some control over the the
films I wanted to make but I feel like
it was a longer process to become a
a pretty good writer whereas being a
director felt more natural to me I just
had a more natural instinct for it
whereas writing felt like work you know
and writing still feels like work to a
certain extent feels like you really
where as when I'm making a film even
though it's hard it ever feels like I
never feels like work it just feels like
you know natural for some reason so I
feel like the writers that that are real
writers are the ones that this that they
speak that language they hear that music
that's their that's their way primary
way of expressing themselves so whether
you were writing a search-and-rescue or
just in general do you rely on a certain
structure or book to help you start the
screenplay
finish it you being a book for the
source material or a book for
inspiration inspiration or writing book
no you know but there is one book that I
you know I probably mentioned this
before there is the that book by Stephen
King on writing which was key when I
started to sit down and do search and
rescue I don't know why cuz Valerie
didn't point me to that book but I think
I either somebody introduced it to me or
I just came across it and was right at
that point where I was you know how am I
gonna do this am I really gonna commit
am I gonna do this
and then I read that book by Stephen
King which is this really thin book I
have you have you read it yeah it's
great it's great it's about his life too
it's not just how it's not just one of
these Mike you know this is how you
write a book or a screenplay it was
there it was very conversational like
his stuff is it was very unpretentious
and it somehow demystified it and made
it easier to start so that book I think
was really key because I felt like I
just needed to kind of I don't know it
just seemed less complicated than like
reading one of those classic
screenwriting
you know like books you know where's the
inciting incident and all that it wasn't
any of that stuff it was just like this
is you know this is how I do it and it
works for me and maybe it'll work for
you and I was like okay you know so that
was key I mean I don't and I actually
recommend that book when I you know when
people say what book that's the book I
recommend for writers I thought it was
good too and I forgot exactly how he
says it's been a few years since I've
read it but when he actually
a writer writer in terms of he was hired
and then it was difficult to finish
things right
without substances or whatever you know
I mean yes it was very interesting now
you wouldn't think that that would be a
problem right you wouldn't write all of
us are waiting to get to a point where
we don't have to worry about a day job
and then he talks about not having a day
job and having to be discipline and
things like that that's a problem I
think a lot of us don't think about no
no I think and also there's a pressure
now all of a sudden it's like you're not
you know now you are this thing you are
this professional things you were
expected to deliver you know and yeah I
just think he made it easy to for the
prospective writer just to just get you
know to realize it yeah this stuff is
probably in you and you just have to be
you know you just have to be serious
about it and get down to business you
know and and it's the it's the
unofficial Mis of it or the then that
not mathematical kind of step-by-step
process that I think made the book good
and it spoke to me anyway because again
I didn't I didn't think that way anyway
I didn't I didn't naturally feel like I
could need it to out I could outline
every single scene of the other of the
movie before I wrote it and in a way it
kind of started to kill the any of the
joy because writing is so hard to me the
discovery of the piece as you write it
is something that is one of the most
enjoyable parts of writing to me because
otherwise you're just executing
something that's already been formed and
to a certain degree I mean that's what
you're doing when you're making a film
but there's such a translation from the
word to the to the image with actors and
everything it's just that's such a huge
translation that it that doesn't feel
boring although I heard like again like
hitch to Hitchcock used to say by time I
made the movie it was so designed that I
was like it was bored to death because I
knew it so well I didn't even want to
show up it was done in my head but for
writing I felt that if it was so laid
out that I would just be like a slave to
this outline like I now I got to write
this you know I'm gonna write this as
opposed to something that you know would
sort of reveal itself
so that to me is like the coolest part
of writing is I win the movie when when
the story starts to reveal itself to you
it becomes a lot of living thing have
you ever followed a strict routine you
seem like you maybe vacillate yeah it
depends on the situation like you know
what search-and-rescue I knew that if I
didn't get up every day and write I
wouldn't do it like it would never get
done I almost did it just to get so I
could just get it over with you know
what I mean like if you just get up and
do it that that's the math I did if I
can write three pages a day it's finite
that means if I can only have only have
the burden of writing three pages a day
that after you know you know 40 days or
whatever it'll be done at least there'll
be something done so just like it was
almost like a diet or something like
just do just do it nobody wants to do it
but you just I can do it I can do it for
a month I can actually do it for a month
now that's why again going back to the
real writer the real writer doesn't
stays on that diet their whole life I
mean they just keep doing it but I also
think that the real writer is addicted
in the same way a filmmaker is in other
words it can't just be a chore as hard
as a writer will say it's hard it can't
be a chore it has to be an addiction
otherwise you will not just like going
to the gym for a lot of people as an
addiction there's something in the
adrenaline or something the you know you
just get jacked up and you now you need
to do this thing so I don't I didn't
continue that once I finished writing
that script then it was it was like okay
now I got to think about like how I'm
gonna make it that's why I don't say I'm
a real I'm not I'm a classic writer
because if that was the case I would
just put that away and start writing the
next thing but to me it's just the step
necessary step so I could now set about
making the movie you know so that's
where I am you know I went through the
writing process so I could make the
movie and you have a campaign on
IndieGoGo yeah we have an IndieGoGo
campaign it's it's it's it's continuing
you know until the end of October and
yeah everything is on there you know we
that was another thing it was also like
you know what's what does it take to
make an IndieGoGo campaign well it takes
at least this this this this and this it
takes a lot of I mean it doesn't it can
be different for everybody but for the
people that that were working with me
they were like you know we really got to
spend a month or two at least two months
of just producing content that that sets
up the campaign in other words I don't
building an awareness and how are you
gonna build that awareness are you just
gonna comment that I'm making a movie or
do you
in our case create a lot of videos a lot
of sort of mini teases and and aspects
of of the content of the story and also
my biography as a filmmaker in the films
I've made all these things it was just
like it was a production of two months
before we even launched the campaign and
then it was all the videos and and stuff
that had to be created for the campaign
itself and even then you know you can do
all that but you you know there's no
guarantee how much you're going to get
but I felt like at least I had to put my
best foot forward and do as best a job
as I could producing that stuff and so
that's what we did do you have a target
date for I want to shoot in January I
want to I won't I want to shoot the film
in January and I think that's doable
and you know like I said the actors are
on board
Kevin Corrigan and Lucy Davis and Barry
Bostwick are all on board and Allan
Havey just joined the cast and that cast
will continue to grow and as soon as
we're like actually greenlit fully
greenly and we're making it on them this
day I know we're actually gonna get
bigger names to commit because there are
a lot of animal-loving celebrities in
this town and and I'm sure they'll want
to get involved in the picture if it's
actually happening they know they only
have to come in for a day or two but
January is what I hope to do it you know
here in LA yeah partly in LA the movie
is set in LA but again you know like all
independent filmmakers will just go
where the where the dollar stretches
farthest we actually shot Dale yeah we
well we actually shot the teaser in
Oakland and that's where a lot of
technicians and people I know and I had
some infrastructure there and so we may
actually shoot a chunk of it in Oakland
and the Bay Area and another chunk of it
here but you know it's a small budget so
you know you wanted like
stretch the money sure yeah
and so the crowdfunding campaign most of
it goes to production or some of it go
to post or well I mean it's it's it's
all towards production imposed I mean
this is just the means of making the
movie and you know I have to think about
like you know if we get enough to get it
in the can and that's what we'll do you
know we'll put we'll put it in the can
and then we'll use that material too if
we have to to raise the additional money
but I feel like you know I think the
most important thing about the process
is that for anybody is just putting it
into play you know like putting it
because there's every reason there's a
million reasons to not do it like and
most of it was just fear of it not
happening or maybe it won't happen or
whatever and I feel like the second I
committed to the idea of making the
thing that that itself and that's this
is not a new concept but that ended up
itself that mindset attracted people to
the to the project and it started to get
its own momentum going and this you know
you build it bit by bit you know you
build a person-by-person dollar by
dollar and you just you just keep going
so I'm very grateful just that I was
able to put it into play yeah as a dog
and so and the dog green so there's this
saying in the entrepreneurial world and
that is don't die today and that means
try to keep the lights on for one more
day we're doing this so why do you think
so many filmmakers don't make another
film hmm how do they get their first
film made and and then go on to their
second and then their third and then
their fourth a lot of them it seems like
don't they don't go past the first and I
can understand why they're tapped out
financially right exhausted they didn't
see it had the kind of distribution that
they wanted obviously yeah but you could
you could ask the same why do people
keep starting these companies over and
over again and then go on to another one
if it doesn't work that's a really good
question yeah I think it's different for
everybody I think that there are people
that only have one
be in them you know or that that in the
making of the movie they realized that
that was enough you know that that was
enough I don't need to make any more
movies or want to make any more movies
but I think most people who are you know
genuine filmmakers if they make a film
regardless of what happens whether it
did well or never with never got
distribution regardless what happens
you're you're constantly searching for a
route to make the next movie whatever it
is and so why they don't make a second
movie may just be like you said it could
be that they don't have the financial
means to make it independently that
perhaps they just maybe they've gone up
for jobs but didn't get them I mean I've
been up for millions of jobs that I
didn't get I don't know I have a lot of
empathy for filmmakers who don't get the
next movie made because I've been one of
them you know I just know what that's
like it's a very painful thing to really
want to work and make something and not
have the the means or maybe even the
psychological emotional foundation to
carry forward because there's a lot of
like you know there's a lot of damage
that gets done if it doesn't all work
out you know when it often most of the
time it doesn't so there has to be
something inside of you that that
somehow pushes you over all that damage
to make the next thing and I think that
those that of us that are able to do
that are lucky but I'm not sure you know
I'm not sure I just know that there are
a lot of people who want to make movies
that don't that don't get a chance you
think they feel like angry that no one
appreciated their work or is it just why
bother I think it's part of it I think
if you put yourself and if you put your
heart and soul in something and nobody
gives a you're gonna be you know
that the the tendency to be bitter or
disappointed or even broken is very
likely it's funny I remember hearing
something about Marlon Brando certainly
you know had
rich and varied career and had no reason
to complain but they said there was a
dividing line in his work it was
everything before one-eyed jacks which
he directed his only the only movie ever
directed and after one-eyed Jack's they
says personality after one-eyed Jack's
was much more I don't really give a
because he talked about how one-eyed
Jack's for him was like he put
everything into that movie he wanted
that movie which said in one movie
direct and he probably wanted direct
more he wanted that to make a difference
and people at the time were like yeah
one-eyed Jack's whatever and so he was
like well this then I don't
want to try and it I'm not gonna do
this again and he only gave this much
instead of this much whether that's true
or not I think it's understandable you
can get yeah you can get despondent and
you can get it's like you know not
wanting to if you had have been in a bad
relationship and your hearts been broken
you're not gonna be like yeah I'm gonna
fall in love again you're kind of like
yeah maybe how you know you like so
there's a lot of went away for that but
I think that if you've been hurt you're
gonna stop you know I know that again
like search and rescue has taken many
years for me to get at this point even
though I've been super lucky to be able
to work on a lot of different projects
over the years I hesitated putting this
into play because I knew I had to do it
myself that I had to do it in an
unorthodox manner that it wasn't gonna
be something that it was all gonna be
set up and I have I knew I had to do
everything and in that and of itself is
kind of like once you start to pile up
all the stuff that you have to do that
that in and of itself could stop you you
know from taking that first step so yeah
I think that that any filmmaking like
any art is populated by a lot of
sensitive people cuz to do anything good
you have to have a certain degree of
sensitivity but that also make makes you
vulnerable to the to what happens in the
real world when things don't go your way
and maybe those people feel it a little
bit more strongly and don't bounce back
as as readily maybe you talked about
dating and relationships reminds me of
going on a date like yeah go alright
I'll have coffee with this person right
here just
like whatever and then the person that
you and you're like I can't I can't even
sure I want to be able to speak he's
right
so and and those are the projects you
want to work on but you're afraid
because you know what if it doesn't work
out right what if they break what if
what if what if the movie and ii was
like what if the movie breaks up with me
you know what I mean right that's really
what it is it's like I'm gonna put my
everything into this and what if the
movie dumps me you know which you know
is funny I never thought about it in
those terms but you know I mean all you
have to do is look at you know Terry
Gilliam and he's me sits and really dumb
things lately which is like Jesus Terry
you're supposed to be the Freak why are
you saying these stupid things but you
know obviously lost in limoges there is
the easiest way of representing that
idea of going after something with
everything you've got and then just to
be sort of smited when everything goes
wrong in the movie doesn't happen so
that experience is something that all
filmmakers who've been doing it for
years know that they've gotten is close
or they may be in that just as in that
case we're actually shooting and it fell
apart so the movie can break up with you
and that's a that can be devastating and
that can be reason enough not to like
start it not to get into another movie
relationship sure or you can make your
hearts of darkness and can film it right
you can just fill you exactly at least
something and then you have two things
that that's a rare instance that's true
that's true I think he was you know as
clearly when you watch hearts of
darkness all he wanted was for that dig
for him to fall off a pier and break his
legs or didn't have to finish the movie
so in that case he wanted out because he
thought he was it up so badly
and it just turned out that of course he
wasn't but yeah I think there when you
see documentary about about filmmakers
going through that that doubt and those
fears those are the healthiest
documentary there's not a lot of them
but those are the ones that I think that
the most beneficial to filmmakers and
and students because you understand that
it's not just oh these are professionals
that now they're there and they couldn't
possibly have self-doubt and they
couldn't possibly be racked with anxiety
it's like no it doesn't matter where you
are in your career you've you're always
if it matters feeling those feelings and
sometimes those feelings can be
overpowering you know you have to be
able to
Ernest that and use it that energy and
some other way to get it done but yeah
we all feel that those pressures and
those those anxieties no matter where
you are whatever stage you're right it's
kind of like with Jim Carrey with the
Netflix that forgive me I'm drawing a
blank on yeah he was willing to show
write various things and a lot of people
I think aren't willing to go there and I
understand why yeah and not everybody is
at the level that Jim Carrey is I think
once you get to a certain level then you
can show all that right you probably
true you know or but people are afraid
people are afraid to expose that for
fear of losing what you have that people
see that vulnerability or that
humaneness that somehow it will
contribute to it though people taking
that away what you've what you've
striven for for so many years but yeah I
think those are the healthiest
documentaries for any filmmaker to see
have you seen people who have quotes
supposedly made it and we won't mention
any names but that feel like they
haven't made it and that really making
it you never really assume that you've
made it that it's really one job to the
next some dry spells some failures a
success that making it is read there's
not really like oh this is oh yeah
that's textbook making it right here
right right right that's a great
question I don't know about I mean I
don't know about other people but I know
it in myself I definitely know it in
myself I think that I am still thinking
about like making it I don't know about
other people because I haven't really
spoken I mean I have friends of mine who
are you know classically big successful
filmmakers but I've never heard them
talk about that they don't think they've
made it maybe they have I mean I think
when you're ambitious and you're
shooting for something maybe you never
really see what you have attained you
know and I think that you know for
someone like myself I know that there
have been plenty of times even recently
where I've been like you know jealous of
somebody else's success or feeling like
I got screwed and then get to make
enough movies or didn't get the kind of
budgets I felt I deserved or things like
that
and it really takes somebody outside
like my wife going you know what you
know like when you you know you're
you're being you know you're whining
about you know we're poor me but think
about how many people would like you
know cut off their arms to have done
what you did and sometimes it takes that
kind of that kind of bucket of cold
water to go yeah yeah you know you're
right you know I'm the luckiest guy on
earth but I think that the ambitious
person is constantly looking to the next
thing anyway so if you're satisfied with
what you've done maybe you're not going
to even do the next thing you can just
kind of go well I did it you know but
the thing that drives I think creative
people is this need to keep doing it so
in a way you keep kind of can't almost
like cancelling out you'd be forgetting
what you did because it's not enough
anyway and I think about that sometimes
it's interesting I think about that
sometimes it's like we spend all this
time gearing up and thinking about it
and then finally making the thing and
then that's gonna be over and then
shortly after that you're kind of like
okay now I got a I'm not happy I got to
do it I got to do another thing I
remember seeing in that great
documentary it came from couch are about
George and my couch are and George couch
are the gradient of experimental
independent filmmaker is making some
crazy project and he they're they're
filming him putting the last touches on
the editing he makes the last cut and as
soon as he does the last cut he goes now
I'm depressed I gotta I gotta make
another movie you know and it's almost
that immediate it's almost like it's
that back to the drug addict thing it's
like you need that thing so I think that
contributes to a lack of perspective
which I know I've had where I'm just so
concentrated on what I need to do next
to make the film whatever it is that
I've forgotten that I've done some
things that I should be happy with and
be like yeah you know you managed to
accomplish that that's good you know so
I think that's maybe that's more typical
than then not I don't know so maybe in
some ways that's a good quality to have
to kind of like almost like forget about
your success a day after it happens you
know because then it's going to keep you
going to the next cuz you're too happy
about it then
you don't eat anything yeah I think it's
gonna be a nice balance I think that if
in the time where you're not getting one
when things are falling apart like even
if you've only made one movie or short
and you're struggling to make the next
thing and you feel like it's never gonna
happen you should still be able to
hopefully call upon what you have done
even if it's just right having written
the screenplay you can say you know what
I accomplished that that was not easy
that not everybody can do that that's
something to be like to feel good about
while I worry about that I'm not making
the next thing like if you can if you
can take that that information and use
that to support yourself and like take
care of yourself I think that's a
healthy thing to remember as opposed to
just being in a constant state of want
or or a constant state of I don't have
and I must be like a junkie again who's
just waiting again get well you know
it's like you in a way you almost need
to remember what you have accomplished
and use that as a as a buoy or something
to lift yourself up when you when you do
have those dry spells which are frequent
you know most of us never get to make a
movie every year or every two years or
even every three years you know it takes
a lot of time and you have to have
something to sustain yourself other than
misery that you're just not making a
movie so you know it's a good question
that makes me think about it you know I
got to stop whining sometimes